das ist ein paar ich mir wünschen würde
dass all die Autofans die ganze Zeit
über ihre Partys hat
auch verstehen wir leben 21000000 müssen
wir verändern sonst geht es auf so
vielen Ebenen und nicht mit dem
Klimaschutz nicht weiter
[Musik]
wir starten direkt mit der ersten Frage
von dreizehn Fragen mit der Konflikt
Frage müssen Innenstädte autofrei werden
oder zumindest weitesgehend autofrei
werden wenn ihr seid ja auf jeden Fall
danke der Zwitter aus grüne Feld und
wenn du sagst nein auf gar keinen Fall
dann geht jetzt wieder aufs gerbefeld
[Musik]
jeder Haushalt besitzt durchschnittlich
mehr als ein Auto in Deutschland die
Zahl der zugelassenen Pkw ist im letzten
Jahr sogar gestiegen und das obwohl wir
gerade jetzt eigentlich alles dafür tun
sollten CO2 einzusparen und das Klima
ist ja nur die eine Sache Staus
vollgepackte Innenstädte Unfälle all das
könnte durch weniger Autoverkehr
reduziert werden sprich mehr
Lebensqualität für alle das sagt
zumindest die eine Seite die andere
Seite ist nicht sicher Autos verbieten
dass es komplett realitätsfern es
schadet der Wirtschaft es schränkt die
Freiheitsrechte ein und diskriminiert
auch noch genau diejenigen die auf ihr
Auto angewiesen sind hier merkt die
Fronten sind verhärtet aber ich bin
eigentlich ganz oft ist den ein oder
anderen Kompromiss finden oder ja
vielleicht sogar eine Lösung wie wir in
Zukunft Mobilität für uns alle aber eben
auch fürs Klima besser gestalten können
aber jetzt erstmal die Frage an euch wo
auf dem Feld wird hier stehen grün oder
gelb Schatz mir gerne in die Kommentare
danke für euch liebe Gäste ab jetzt wenn
er der anderen Seite in einem Argument
in einem. Was auch immer zustimmt dann
könnt ihr gerne einen Schritt nach vorne
gehen und wenn ihr der anderen Seite
überhaupt nicht zustimmt in etwas
meinetwegen auch während die andere
Person redet und er möchte das unbedingt
zum Ausdruck bringen dann geht er einen
Schritt zurück ins hintere Feld meinte
es natürlich heute so viele wie möglich
von euch ihrem Kompromiss Feld zu sehen
mal gucken ob das gelingt ich beginne
jetzt mit dir Sophia du hast ein
instagram-account der Fall von Fotos und
Videos von dir da mit Autos ist man
merkt Autos und deine absolute
Leidenschaft du liebst das über alles
warum wird mir glaube ich so in die
Wiege gelegt einfach runter spätestens
mit meinem Führerschein dann war für
mich klar Autos werden später mein Leben
erfüllen allerdings werde ich heute mal
meine line schafft außen vor lassen
sondern tatsächlich mal das große Ganze
betrachten und wirklich auch mit
einbeziehen was vielleicht für die
meisten Menschen am sinnvollsten wäre
eine Stimme geben die sich für die
Verkehrswende einsetzen wollen wir
wollen klar machen dass das Auto in der
Stadt viel zu viel Platz einnimmt dass
wir die brauchen zurückholen müssen und
wollen einfach zeigen wie eine
lebenswerte Stadt der Zukunft aussehen
kann und dazu gehören eben keine Autos
das bedeutet also die Autos sollen jetzt
gar nicht unbedingt verschwinden und
jeder soll sie abschaffen oder verkaufen
sondern die sollen raus aus der
Innenstadt oder wie genau kann man sich
das vorstellen genauso ich bin jetzt
nicht die Autos perse aber gerade in der
Innenstadt ist der öffentliche Raum
einfach ein unfassbar wertvolles Gut und
den können wir nicht vorstellen mit
Autos das ist einfach überhaupt nicht
verhältnismäßig gerade in Innenstädten
und genauso wenig was verhältnismäßig
wenn man sich überlegt wie das für ein
hohes Sicherheitsrisiko es Autos
ausmachen wie viele Missionen sie haben
es gibt 1000 Gründe die gegen den Auto
sprechen gerade in der Innenstadt auf
einem auf dem Land finde ich wieder
normal anders aus auch da
wäre es schön wenn nicht alle aufs Auto
angewiesen sind aber gerade in der
Innenstadt ist überhaupt nicht frei
Alicia was hältst du von Ninas Ideen und
noch zwei Fahrten pro Jahr macht mich
traurig ehrlicherweise und ich finde es
strengt auch einfach ein in der
persönlichen Freiheit also an der
aktuellen Debatte rund ums Auto ärgert
mich einfach dass die Autos zu
wahnsinnig böse angesehen werden und
auch die größer die Autos die größer die
Motoren dass du böser sind die Menschen
die da drin sitzen ist werden immer mehr
Fahrradwege gebaut die zweispurigen
Straßen werden auf einspurig
runtergesetzt in dem Moment haben wir
Stau also autofahren wird regelrecht
madig gemacht die Frage die mir jetzt
gerade kam es wenn wir zwölf Arten haben
wo steht dann das Auto wenn wir es nicht
nutzen also wir können ja nicht
irgendwie 12 Arten machen einmal im
Monat und den Rest dann dann steht da
auch rum und wahrscheinlich stets dann
auch in Innenstadt rum genau deswegen
ist es ja auch sinnvoll wenn wir nicht
alle ein eigenes Auto besitzen weil das
Auto auch jetzt gerade schon 23 Stunden
am Tag einfach nur rumsteht insofern
denke ich es ist viel sinnvoller da auf
sharing Variante überzugehen und
zuschauen okay wie können wir die Autos
max die wir wirklich brauchen maximal in
Bewegung halten damit sie uns eben nicht
den öffentlichen Raum wegnehmen Katja
Alicia macht den Vorschlag traurig macht
er dich auch traurig stimmte zu ich
glaube Mobilität ist einfach so wie
immer erst auf uns gucken und kucken wie
geht's uns mit der Mobilität ist die
Klimakrise die uns anfeuert aber
eigentlich auch ein gerechtigkeits Thema
und deswegen kann ich durchaus traurig
verstehen weiß natürlich auch um die
eigene persönliche Mobilität geht aber
es geht ja auch immer um andere die wir
einschränken bis Auto also tatsächlich
habe ich das Gefühl dass es jetzt
einfach mal an der Zeit ist alle anderen
die vielleicht kein Auto haben oder sich
nicht leisten können mal in den
Vordergrund drücken und ich glaube bei
Städten vor dem Auto hatten wir das ja
wir hatten Begegnungszonen wir konnten
einander begegnen ohne dass man Gefahr
lief irgendwie verletzt zu werden und
das heißt nicht dass die Autos alle
Privilegien verlieren aber auf jeden
Fall teilen müssen also es muss genau so
unbequem sein Auto zu fahren wie z.b. zu
Fuß zu gehen wir denn du wirst Sprecher
des Verbandes der Automobilindustrie das
heißt dass tagtäglich mit dem Thema
Mobilität zu tun warum brauchen wir denn
Meinung nach keine autofreie Innenstädte
um eben Klima und Lebensqualität was
gerade schon angesprochen wurde zu
verbessern also ich glaube in dem sie
sind wir uns einig Klima verbessern
Lebensqualität verbessern das sehe ich
ganz genauso ich glaube immer nur dass
Verbote der falsche Weg sind es gibt
Menschen die sind weiterhin auf das Auto
angewiesen Pendler Familie mit Kindern
Menschen in Schichtarbeit all diese
Menschen können ohne Auto teilweise gar
nicht ihren Job und ihr Leben
verwirklichen in Deutschland arbeiten
über 800 000 Menschen in der
Automobilindustrie fast zwei Millionen
Arbeitsplätze hängen ihn direkt an der
Autoindustrie und bei allen
Entscheidungen die wir treffen müssen
wir immer daran denken wie wir auch
deren Lebensrealitäten berücksichtigen
können und da gibt es ja Lösung man kann
ja durchaus auch den Verkehrsfluss und
auf dem ruhenden Verkehr in der Stadt
runterfahren es gibt so viele
Möglichkeiten die in der Digitalisierung
liegen ja wo der immer schon mal
angesprochen Shared Services Bullriding
Alters das sollte man ja auch nutzen da
sind wir auch dafür aber grundsätzlich
gesehen sollte man immer er auf
Innovationen setzen statt auf Katja du
bist ein Schritt zurück gegangen und
verlässt gleich zu Studio
tatsächlich geht es nicht darum Verbotes
fahr mal als radfahren der Person hat zu
Fuß gehende Person als jemand im
Rollstuhl durch Berlin Hamburg und jede
Stadt was so viele Verbote bei dem Auto
einfach unausgesprochen Rechte gegeben
werden ich fühle mich nicht
gleichberechtigt wenn ich radfahre in
Hamburg und ich fühle mich als eine
Person die immer auf sich aufpassen muss
also Verbote sind unausgesprochen für
Menschen ohne außerschulisches da also
ich fahre auch Fahrrad in Berlin
natürlich kann man da also ich finde
auch dass man da was tun kann damit das
vielleicht mehr Fahrradwege gibt das
spricht ja gar nichts dagegen aber ich
glaube grundsätzlich Gewinn ist halt
dieses ganze gegeneinander ausspielen
nicht Auto sondern Fahrrad der komplett
falsche Wege willst doch sowohl Auto als
das Fahrrad als auf Scooter als auch zu
Fuß alles nebeneinander also ich
verstehe gar nicht warum man das
gegeneinander ausspielt wer du bist ein
wenig Schritt zurück gegangen warum auf
das Argument vor dich gerade mal
eingehen bezüglich dass man als
Fahrradfahrer eigentlich
benachteiligte also es werden in den
Städten immer mehr Fahrradwege gebaut es
gibt in vielen vielen Großstädten
mittlerweile auch schon Gebiete wo
ja Straßen gesperrt sind für Autos z.b.
Hamburg ich weiß nicht jungfernsteg
glaube ich
z.b. ist jetzt auch so ein Thema und
diese Straße die oder die Innenstädte
leiden ja auch darunter weil eben auch
nicht mal dieser Spontanität da ist dass
man sich in sein Auto setzen und mal
eben irgendwo in die Stadt fährt zum
Einkaufen das heißt die ganzen Läden die
jetzt schon darunter leiden dass ist
immer mehr Onlineshops gibt und dass man
immer mehr online bestellen kann sie
werden früher oder später noch mehr
darunter leiden wenn es eben nicht mehr
diese Spontanität gibt es für die
Menschen mal einfach so in die Stadt zu
fahren ganz kurz einmal an Grünefeld
also ihr könnt auch einfach am Rande des
Feldes sein weil sonst seid ihr nachher
aus dem Studio raus das war ein bisschen
schade aber warum hat sich gerade nach
hinten bewegt ich will diese Debatten
unglaublich anstrengend weil es
eigentlich nichts anderes ist als
erwarte patisson das was unserer Seite
ja die ganze Zeit vorgeworfen wird als
die Leute die sagen wir wollen dass es
weniger Fahrzeuge in der Innenstadt gibt
ist dass uns ständig gesagt mit naja ihr
wollt irgendwie die Leute gegeneinander
ausspielen aber wir wurden ja
jahrzehntelang gegen Autofahrer in den
ausgespielt und jetzt benutzt ihr unsere
Argumente nämlich dass sie
keine Ahnung die Krankenschwester oder
irgendjemand mit der Mobilität ja sonst
eingeschränkt ist wenn wir Autos
verbieten diejenigen die strikt gegen
autofreie Städte sind würde ich aber
erstmal sagen check mal eure Privilegien
warum seid ihr dagegen jetzt ist einfach
nur dass sie keine Lust habe eure
Komfortzone zu verlassen oder habt ihr
wirklich triftige Gründe und wenn es
euch wirklich darum geht mega schnell
durch die Stadt zu reisen dann geht eine
Mücke Nürnberg was ihr wollt und was man
dort gab aber bitte verpestet damit
nicht unsere Innenstädte hat sich der
VDA und alle Autofans jemals dafür
eingesetzt dass der ÖPNV ausgebaut wird
wann ist das eigentlich jemals geschehen
seit Jahrzehnten passiert da gar nicht
die Felix und ich stell das auf daneben
auf die Frage warum wird auf einem BMW
Mini ein Auto das so groß ist wie die
wann ist das eigentlich passiert und
warum und warum wurden wir nicht gefragt
ob das cool ist das ein Auto dass wir
ein Parkplatz braucht plötzlich zwei
braucht und das gleiche Farbe muss man
auch dazu also einmal und die Fahrzeuge
sind ja nicht besser geworden kommst
dann gehen wir
dann nicht mehr gesehen werden
kann
erst bei den Innenstadt Probleme Größe
von Autos man muss das schon noch alles
in ein wenig unterscheiden es gibt auch
viele kleine Modelle die neu
rausgekommen sind und wenn es um den
Ausbau von ÖPNV geht also da kann man
alle Position nachlesen wir sind absolut
dafür dass der ÖPNV ausgewählt ich habe
jetzt auf einen glaube ich jeder meine
Aussagen klargemacht Alternativen
schaffen dann kann man darüber
diskutieren welche Lösung es gibt man
genau das passiert
Cannabis im Kundenverkehr angeht bin ich
komplett beide ja also man kann Systeme
finden es gibt mittlerweile z.b. wieder
mal Digitalisierung Autos die sich
gegenseitig über freie Parkplätze
informieren und dadurch wird z.b. dieser
ganze Verkehr verziert oder dass man
beispielsweise sagt okay wir machen mehr
in Parkhäusern ja z.b. könnte man sagen
okay wir erleichtern die Zufahrten zu
Parkhäusern dafür können wir vielleicht
sogar bestimmte
Straßenverkehrs beruhigen machen aber
die Zufahrten zu den Parkhäusern müssen
diminished also würde man ruhenden
Verkehr reduzieren du sagst Innovation
wie z.b. Carsharing und so weiter das
Wort Innovation ist er jetzt schon sehr
sehr gefallen oder auch E-Auto sie sind
schön und gut die bringen dir aber in
der Regel überhaupt gar nichts warum
[Musik]
argumentiert dass das nicht geht weil
die elektrisch sind und dadurch
letztendlich die Sitzhöhe höher ist und
eine Rampe in diese Fahrzeuge nicht
einzubauen ist und ich stell mir die
Frage wie deine Stadt wie Hamburg oder
Hannover das zulassen konnte wenn es als
elevation gefeiert wird aber
gleichzeitig behinderte Menschen ganz
bewusst dann auch ausliest und den
Zugang auf die Frage es gibt bisher kein
einziges Fahrzeug das elektrisch ist
dass Menschen die auf den Rollstuhl
angewiesen sind überhaupt benutzen
können und jede Ladesäule die momentan
in Berlin oder in Deutschland
installiert wird ist für Menschen die im
Rollstuhl sitzen nicht zugänglich weil
die Steckdose tot sind und wir bauen
diese Dinger gerade zu Tausenden aus und
die hätten es so leicht gehabt das von
Anfang an mitzudenken aber es wird nicht
getan weil auch hier wieder eine
gesetzliche Regulierung fehlt und eine
Verpflichtung und dieses Argument dass
ich dann oft aus der Seiten der
Privatwirtschaft höre ja wir müssen das
irgendwie auf Freiwilligkeit machen wir
alles für alles aber wenn es nicht
reguliert ist dann passiert es dich
genauso wie die Gleichberechtigung
zwischen Mann und Frau in der
Automobilindustrie aufwecken nicht
freiwillig geschehen ist in
Führungsetagen musste es repariert
werden genau das gleiche mit CO2
Reduktion es musste reguliert werden es
geht nicht freiwillig an das gelbe Feld
ihr könnt euch gerne positionieren ein
Schritt auf Frauen zugehen wenn er euch
dazu bewegt hat also ich denke dass in
der Zukunft je mehr E-Autos es geben
wird und je mehr der Ausbau von
Ladesäulen stattfinden wird gerade auch
da vielleicht auf den
Behindertenparkplätzen auch viel mehr
auf das Thema eingegangen wird das ist
ich kann dass ich habe keine
Berührungspunkte damit deswegen bin ich
jetzt auch keinen Schritt nach vor oder
nach zurückgegangen weil ich das nicht
einschätzen kann aber du kannst es jetzt
mit seiner persönlichen Einschätzung
vielleicht besser einschätzen ihr könnt
euch ja zu hören du kannst deinen
Behindertenparkplätzen
bin ich seiner Meinung
ein Schritt entgegenkommen nur finde ich
das
später gerade nicht so richtig zum Thema
ob Auto im Auto frei werden sollen Katja
warum ist es denn eben doch wichtig wenn
wir über eine autofreie Stadt Innenstadt
sprechen ja oder nein auch diese ganzen
Diversität und Inklusion steeman
mitzudenken also wer sie das noch
aktuelle ich habe es mittlerweile in
Ehren entlassen worden der Steuer aber
wir uns das Ministerium z.b. angucken
das in den ersten drei Etagen keine
Frauen zu finden und die Männer die dort
tätig sind sind einander sehr ähnlich
und ich glaube wenn ich mit 14 Katjas am
Tisch sitzt und ich habe super Idee dann
sagen alle 13 Katjas ja für die auch gut
gut gut die kommen raus aus dem Raum
sich einig und haben auch Menschen
vergessen weil sie halt nicht am Tisch
sitzen die ganzen Auto gibt für die seit
2011 gibt war nur Auto befestigen um ein
Transport mit es waren keine
Umweltinitiativen aber es waren keine
Angy aus da war es war kein fnv an Bord
und das sind Sachen dass das kann ich
auch gar nicht Vorwurf platzieren weil
wenn eine homogene Gruppe über ein
Problem spricht dann ist es nicht sich
einig hat aber Menschen bei Essen deine
Stimme wir brauchen und ich habe noch
nie gehört dass wir uns um Minderheiten
kümmern der Mehrheit etwas geschadet
wird sondern im Gegenteil meistens ist
es sogar so dass zwei Sitzbänke an
Haltestellen hochschwangere Frauen
Menschen die nicht mehr so gut gehen
kann oder auch Kinder also die haben
alle was davon und ich glaube diese
Inklusion heißt halt auch diesen diesen
Fokus mal ein bisschen Auto aufmachen
und auf die Bedürfnisse zu schauen und
ich hab's Transportmittel also um auf
die Bedürfnisse aller eingehen zu können
finde ich es da der öffentliche Verkehr
eigentlich der falsche Weg natürlich
zeig mir ausbauen aber dennoch würde es
trotzdem immer noch gewisse Gruppen
einschränken genauso wie Familien mit
Kindern wenn ich mir vorstellen würde
ich hätte zwei drei kleine Kinder und
müsste immer mit Öffis fahren und das
eine Kind muss dorthin das andere Kind
muss dahin dass das ist sowas aktuell
zumindest noch
einschränkend für solche Gruppen und
z.b. ich könnt mir auch nicht vorstellen
dass mein über 80-jähriger Opa mit dem
Carsharing in der Innenstadt irgendwo
der kann nicht mal mit dem Handy
klarkommen also an die so Leute muss man
ja auch mitdenken und da kann man auch
nicht sagen ja gut dann müssen sie das
Lernen mein Opa der wäre aufgeschmissen
wenn er nicht mehr mit seinem Auto
unterwegs sein könnte weil du hast dich
nach vorne bewegt ganz kurz ja wegen
Schritt nach vorne bewegt Berlin dir
zustimme dass
wir natürlich alle Menschen mit denken
sollten hat es aber auch meiner Ansicht
nach das ganz viele Menschen bisher
nicht mitbedacht wurden und dass sie
auch unterscheiden müssen
verlassen der eigene Komfortzone also
inwieweit ist Autofahren für uns Hobby
und inwieweit ist Autofahren für uns
aber auch wirklich ne ne alternativlose
Notwendigkeit und bei der Frage wurden
Menschen mit Behinderung z.b. meistens
vergessen und das hast du gerade
ausgeführt hast 50% aller prekär
verdienen Menschen haben keinen
Führerschein und kein Auto und den sagen
wir jetzt ja sorry Pech gehabt die
persönliche Freiheit ist erstmal
wichtiger wir brauchen die sind aus
Hausklima Gründen und aus der sozialen
Gerechtigkeit heraus weil die Menschen
Ducati skizziert hast eine Frau und
Alleinerziehende ohne Führerschein ohne
Möglichkeit Auto zu fahren mit Kindern
was bieten wir als Deutschland als
hochentwickeltes Land wir nehmen einfach
hin dass wir solche Leute nicht
mitdenken und sagen alle die im Auto
sitzen machen dass sie müssen das
Weiterführen nein wir müssen anders
denken wir müssen gucken was ist mit
solchen Menschen die nicht viel
verdienen für die Arme auf den auf den
Balkonen geklatscht toll und jetzt auf
einmal sagen wir nee wir machen das
weiter wie bisher und schließen Sie
weiterhin aus und das da wäre aber damit
also irgendwie spielt das Argumente
gegeneinander aus die eigentlich nicht
gleiche Richtung gehen das verstehe ich
nicht weil wir alle sagen ok es gibt
Menschen mit unterschiedlichsten
Lebensqualität Lebenswirklichkeiten ja
ob jetzt mit Auto oder ohne Auto auch
Gutverdiener oder schlecht für ihn ja
grundsätzlich haben wir doch alle gesagt
Mobilität ist etwas was wir alle
brauchen dass wir im täglichen um um um
zur Arbeit zu kommen um am Kulturleben
teilzuhaben das ist ja gabs das angetan
aktuell ich bin noch nicht fertig also
Mobilität ein Menschen ermöglichen so
und natürlich kann man jetzt immer ein
Beispiel rauspicken wo was nicht
funktioniert fakt ist aber dass die
aktuelle Situation in Städten nicht
hergibt dass man die Autos quasi sagt
dir wir wir wir machen jetzt autofreie
Innenstädte weil man dann da mit
bestimmten Menschen das Leben erschweren
würde weil die Alternativen doch noch
gar nicht da sind und man muss doch man
muss doch die Dinge auch zu Ende denken
und das geht halt schon in so eine
Richtung wo ich sage das ist
weit weg von der Lebensrealität von
manchen Menschen also vielleicht nicht
in der Stadt aber spätestens dann wenn
wir auf dem Land bin würde man diesen
Menschen wirklich einfach sagen ok
Teilhabe ist halt nicht für jeden
zugänglich seht ihr seid das Thema der
Eltern auf andere Themen kommen wir
reden ja nur von Innenstädten was gibt
das für Leute vom Land müssen um zu
arbeiten
Hobby Fahrten sondern da wo ich hinfahre
fahre ich aus einem guten Grund weil ich
was besorgen muss was abholen muss keine
Ahnung weil ich hier irgendwo einen
Termin habe oder so also Hobby fahren wo
ich mich ins Auto setzen und sage ich
mache jetzt mal irgendwie coole Musik an
und fahr mal eine halbe Stunde rum bei
mir langweilig ist sorry aber mit 18 Mal
gemacht was mache ich nicht dafür habe
ich gar keine Zeit da wo er denkst du
dann kommt die Statistik dass ein Auto
nur 45 Minuten fährt am Tag
durchschnittlich mit 1,3 Personen sind
alle so wie du oder sind da vielleicht
doch ein paar Leute dabei die sogar
fünfhundert Meter zum Briefkasten mit
dem Auto fahren es gibt wahrscheinlich
Leute die 500 GL 500 m zum Briefkasten
fahren weil sie es einfach nicht mehr
laufen können weil sie vielleicht C&A
wollen aus der Puste sind was auch immer
aber diese
Woche
nicht ab es ist einfach so die die
ganzen Bus und Bahn ist alles sollen
keine deine Autofahrten seien wir mal 10
pro Woche was auch immer wäre ersetzbar
durch z.b. ÖPNV
nee also da wo ich wohne
weil es gibt immer Personen geben die
auf ein Auto angewiesen sind es wird
immer eine Feuerwehr gegen geben der
Lieferverkehr der transportiert
wahnsinnig viele waren der muss
natürlich auch irgendwie Motiv
motorisiert stattfinden aber ich glaube
eine Auto reduzierte Innenstadt ist auf
jeden Fall möglich er muss auf jeden
Fall möglich da anbei beim Privatbesitz
anzusetzen und ich glaube davon haben
wir dann alle was und ich meine auch die
Leute die Autofahren sind ja auch mal zu
Fuß und mit dem Fahrrad unterwegs und
haben dann auch ein Vorteil davon wenn
es mehr Platz gibt wenn irgendwie man
sich höristraße gehen kann und ich
glaube einfach da müssen wir ein
bisschen umdenken das eben wir wollen
alle mobil sein und dass das dass dieses
mobil sein nicht mit dem Auto verknüpft
wird sondern eben schon gerade in der
Innenstadt über den ÖPNV abgedeckt
werden kann übers Fahrrad und die Leute
auch oder jetzt z.b. Menschen die sagen
wenn sie wird niemals mit dem
fahrradfahren tun oder treffen diese
Aussage jetzt auch weil die Verhältnisse
so sind wie sie sind und weil die
Straßen z.b. so unsicher sie und sie das
Verkehrsmittel nicht nutzen wollen und
ich glaube wenn quasi weniger Autos
fahren würden würden z.b. auch mehr
Leute auch vielleicht ältere Leute
umsteigen und genau darum geht's auch
also wenn ihr jetzt auch sagt irgendwie
eure Großeltern die müssen Autofahren
ich glaube es gibt ein Punkt wo es auch
für ganz also für sehr alte Leute
unverantwortlich ist Auto zu fahren und
ein viel größeres Sicherheitsrisiko und
dann muss man den auch Alternativen
anbieten genauso wie Leute unter 18
keinen Führerschein haben die kann man
nicht ausschließen die sollen auch mobil
sein und in der Innenstadt haben wir
kurze Wege oder irgendwie in Berlin
einen sehr gut ausgebauten ÖPNV und ich
glaube darauf kann man sich verlassen
und den pushen und ich glaube nur auch
dass es halt nicht reicht nur Anreize zu
schaffen jetzt fahrt alle mit dem ÖPNV
wir verlegten den Takt ist das wichtig
aber wenn es dem Auto so bequem gemacht
wird oder ist so bequem ist ein Auto zu
besitzen weil der Parkplatz nichts
kostet weil man das einfach überall
hinstellen kann weil man sich damit
bewegen kann weil es wahnsinnig
subventioniert wird dann sehe ich auch
nicht die Leute umsteigen aber was genau
willst du denn dann passieren an euch
gelbes Feld dass ihr sagen würdet ihr
würdet auf euer Auto verzichten jetzt
mal ganz wir können uns ja jetzt
ausdenken was wir wollen hier in diesem
Raum was müsste passieren gar nichts
also ich würde er mir keine Möglichkeit
kurz noch zu dem Argument was sagen ich
habe vor einigen Jahren beschlossen dass
ich innerhalb Deutschlands nur mit dem
Auto Reise obwohl ich alle Flüge bezahlt
bekomme von meinen Kunden ich könnte
jederzeit mit dem Flugzeug von A nach B
fliegen egal wohin innerhalb
Deutschlands ich habe aber gesagt nein
ich sehe es nicht ein so viel
Luftverschmutzung oder
Umweltverschmutzung einzugehen nur für
ich sag mal relativ kurzen Weg also
nehme ich dafür das Auto würde das Thema
Autos abschaffen in Innenstädten Thema
werden
dann würde ich wieder fliegen und da ist
halt die Frage ob das wieder im Sinne
aller wäre wenn die Menschen wieder viel
mehr ungefähr schlafen legt man statt
welcher Flughafen liegt in der
Innenstadt na ja man muss ja irgendwie
eine Innenstadt kommen wenn ich jetzt
von München bis nach Hamburg Reise dann
kann ich das einfach mit dem Auto tun
oder sterben oder mit der Bahn das geht
sogar schneller und du musst nicht vom
Flughafen fahren aber mit der Bahn ist
meistens weniger Spritpreise
wir sind flexibel hier in
Düsseldorf
[Musik]
öffentliche Verkehrsmittel
fühlt dann trotzdem nicht dazu dass die
Leute auch vom Auto auf dem ÖPNV
wirklich Umschau weil dann habe ich
nämlich genau das Thema die Leute die
gar kein Auto fahren wollen sondern
müssen können da wiederum sagen ok geil
es gibt die Option vielleicht auch aus
finanziellen Gründen und ich denke da
wird viel ergeben die umsteigen würden
die sagen würden ich würde viel lieber
die Öffis nehmen klar gut da wir darum
anderes Thema als Frau will ich nachts
nicht mehr der Öffis nehmen aber es
würden glaube ich viel viel mehr Leute
gerade die die ihm nicht eigentlich auf
ihr Auto oder unbedingt auf ihr Auto
angewiesen sein wollen umsteigen ich
gebe die Frage auch direkt man euch
weiter was müssen sich dann für euch
verändern dass ihr sagen würdet ich
würde komplett auf mein Auto verzichten
bzw was für Alternativen würdet ihr
dafür brauchen schreibs mal in die
Kommentare ich würde gerne noch mal zu
dem Thema Privilegien zurückkommen Katja
wird sich viel damit auseinander warum
das Verkehrssystem in Deutschland und
auch grundsätzlich rassistisch und
sexistisch ist vielleicht kannst du das
noch mal erklären warum ist das
überhaupt so unter den Personen mit
denen ich für mein Buch gesprochen habe
sind viele gewesen die haben gesagt ich
muss Autofahren ich will das gar nicht
ich mag noch nicht mehr Autofahren das
hängt bei einer älteren Dame an wo der
man Parkinson hat die war lange Zeit
radfahren muss jetzt mit 76 Autofahren
weil der Mann halt freiwillig verzichtet
in Deutschland wird es ja nicht verboten
es gab mir Transfrau die zweimal
zusammengeschlagen worden an
Haltestellen und er die sagt mein Auto
ist mein safe space bei ihr in
Deutschland es nicht schafft für mich
eine eine gute Umgebung zu schaffen ich
will aber nicht Autofahren ich will das
ihre Idee war z.b. das in einem Waggon
Übermenschen mitfahren da kann man
Einstiegshilfe machen da kann man
Auskunft erteilen dass das bieten wir
denen aber nicht rassistisch heißt ich
meine kein Bescheid alle quattro wohl
Jasmina viert für Kinder eine schwarze
Frau die hat auch Auto obwohl sie es
nicht will obwohl es gegen die Zukunft
ihrer Kinder ist weil sie als schwarze
Frau mit diesen Kindern unterwegs immer
angepöbelt wird und das sind Sachen die
ins Auto treiben nicht weil das Auto
tolles als Lösung soll die machen so
eine Art bypassing um gesellschaftliche
Katjas das dann aber nicht ein Argument
für Autos nein weil die Menschen die
nicht Autofahren können und wollen die
sind weiterhin dieser Gefahr ausgesetzt
die bleiben teilweise an den Orten wo
sich feiern ist es hell wird also ne
alle Sachen die ich erfahren habe und
nicht auf weiß dass man ein ganz ehrlich
auf dem Land ist das auch ganz auf dem
Problem dass die Leute alkoholisiert
fahren weil es keine Alternativen wissen
glaubt keiner mein Auto wieder so
spricht das schon für das Aussehen es
spricht spricht nicht fürs Auto in dem
Moment wo nicht jeder Auto fahren kann
ich nicht boy aber ich meine man einfach
hat im letzten halbes Jahr und
Einfassungen renommiertes Umfrage zu
zwei Unfall gemacht ich meine da da
kommt halt raus das wirklich die
deutliche Mehrheit der Menschen Deutsch
und sagt die können ihren Alltag ohne
Auto gar nicht Meister schlimm genug
also ich finde das Beste was wir
eigentlich machen können ist doch
wirklich einfach produktive Lösung
finden z.b. mehr machen für diese ganzen
Lösung
würde ja auch Services & Shared Services
Verband ja genauso
industriegas haben weil sie gesellt war
gesetzlich verpflichtet wurde das heißt
ich hatte ein Gespräch mit dem Thema
folgenvorschau mojib Latif Kiel und ich
hatte gefragt haben die Hoffnung haben
sie Hoffnung dass die Klima Klimawandel
angeht und er meinte ja ich habe
Hoffnung weil wir sind gesellschaftlich
dazu in der Lage Dinge zu verändern wenn
die Notwendigkeit dafür wir konnten FCKW
verbieten und es wurde prophezeit dass
die Kühlschrank Industrie demnächst
pleite geht wir könnten den Katalysator
kannst nicht machen jedes Fahrzeug die
Automobilindustrie in Deutschland hat
gesagt danach sind wir pleite was hat
Sie damals gesagt in den 80er 90er
Jahren und ein Scheiß es passiert die
ist nicht pleite gewesen im Gegenteil
die Fahrzeuge wurden immer größer und
wenn du jetzt endlich mal verpflichten
würde gesetzt und ich also die Politik
in die Verantwortung nehmen zu sagen wir
schaffen wir es jetzt endlich mal die
ganze Aufmerksamkeit der
Automobilindustrie zu nehmen und sehen
in App NV und Alternativen zu stecken
und genauso gesetzliche poliert
weiterzumachen zu sagen die Autos dürfen
nicht mehr als soundsoviel Umwelt
verschmutzen die Autos dürfen nicht mehr
so und so groß sein und und dir als
sollte nicht mehr irgendwie als sonst so
viel Prozent Parkplätze in der Stadt
geben dann würde ich der ganze Spaß zu
selber regulieren aber freiwillig
passiert dass Milch von Seiten der
Automobilindustrie
schon viel eher bevor er nicht
ausreichend
[Musik]
pferdefleischer im Moment darüber nach
sich ein E Auto zu kaufen was ist das
größte oder das wichtigste Kriterium
eine ausreichende Flächen de
Ladeinfrastruktur was haben wir nicht
eine ausreichende flächendeckende
Ladeinfrastruktur hängt total hinterher
wir selbst also die Automobilhersteller
wir sind Europa Weltmeister was
Autoservice in deutschen Hersteller
haben da wirklich den anschluss absolut
gewonnen sie sind sogar in in in die
Firma Position gegangen beim
automatisierten fahren sind wir sogar
dass das also erste das Land was als
erstes eingesetzt, hatte damit wir auch
dazwischen können aber es muss jetzt
auch mal investiert werden also E-Autos
lösen meiner Meinung nach vor allem in
den Städten einfach nicht das Problem
also ich habe das Gefühl darf ich kurz
fragen was ist denn das Problem das
Problem ist also meiner Meinung nach
sind wir so sehr an am also hängen so
sehr am Auto fest das ist jetzt eben
dann unbedingt das E-Auto sein soll und
welches Problem verursacht das Auto für
dich in der Innenstadt denn auch egal ob
im Auto oder für auch egal ob mit oder
ein Verbrenner nimmt in der Innenstadt
wahnsinnig viel Platz beispielsweise
okay dann Berlin höre Parkhäuser dann
ist das Problem schon mal erledigt aber
also oder weniger Autos
Gegenstand den du brauchst auf der
Straße und es ist auch nicht kostenlos
ich zahl an jeder Ecke an irgendeine
parcourslauf jeden Parkplatz auf jeden
Fall Parkdeck er zahlt man Geld zum
Parken ich weiß nicht wodurch man hier
in Berlin ist nicht überall kann es ist
nicht überall so bei kommt langsam aber
hauptsächlich kostenpflichtig ja und
dann kostet es für Anwohner irgendwie 20
€ im Jahr das ist aber steht aber nicht
im Verhältnis dazu dass ein ein großer
Sohn einer Großstadt lebt wo ich
ansonsten irgendwie 400 Euro für zehn
Quadratmeter Zimmer zahlen muss also ich
finde es einfach irgendwann muss ich
überlegen der öffentliche Raum müssen
wahnsinnig wertvolles Gut das kann man
nicht einfach den kann man nicht
vorstellen wenn gleichzeitig so ein
Problem gibt es zu wenig Grünflächen
gibt oder zuwenig Spielplätze aber das
könnte man doch eh sie regeln indem man
jedes neu gebaute Gebäude erstmal
ordentlich unterkellert und riesengroßen
in Tiefgarage reinmacht und viel viel
mehr Parkdecks baut viel höher dass man
Autos Blasi übereinander vielmehr
stapeln kann dann heiser du wärst in
Autobestand nicht wiederzusehen
nicht reduzieren du versuchst er jetzt
leer es geht ja gerade um den Platz und
das wäre ein Lösungsvorschlag
aber als Parkhäuser
könnt euch gerne auf mich zu bewegen
einen Schritt auf mich zugehen wenn ihr
mir zustimmt
[Musik]
höhere Parkgebühren oder an sich solche
Konzepte da muss man aber auch wieder
mit bedenken dass es sozial gerecht ist
also ist mir wirklich wichtig weil es
gibt auch Menschen für die aufs Auto
angewiesen sind für die sind diese
höheren Parkgebühren eben nicht einfach
leistbar und er alle diese Lösung oder
Transformation Mobilität seine muss so
gestaltet werden dass sie sozial gerecht
ist und Sozialausschusses und bei dem
Lösungsvorschlag wenn man noch einbaut
dass man es so macht das auch die
mitgenommen werden für die sich das
vielleicht also die Unterstützung
bekommen die sich das nicht einfach
leisten können dann gehe ich gerne im
Schritt nach vorne machen das können wir
gerne hinzufügen
[Musik]
können dass wir nicht Auto fahren
sollten und das ist etwas wo ich gerne
für die Leute eine alternative
bereithalten würde das wenn sie merken
ich kann das nicht mehr ich will das
nicht mehr dass sie da auch mobil sein
können und Relaunch alternative das sind
jetzt eure Schlagwörter für die
Kompromiss Runde ihr könnt euch jetzt
gerne die Köpfe zusammenstecken und euch
jeweils Kompromiss Vorschläge für die
andere Seite überlegen
[Musik]
also immer das Einzelschicksale genutzt
werden um nichts
[Musik]
Parkhäuser für Anwohner aber auch
Besucher von Innstetten
auf Innovation zu setzen aber das hatten
wir ja schon öfter angesprochen vor
allem Pool Services auszuweiten Shared
Services auszuweiten den Menschen diese
Möglichkeit zu geben sodass sie alle
mitgenommen werden und eben auch
wirklich die ganzen Potenziale zu nutzen
die in der Digitalisierung liegen er hat
da kann man das ganze verbessern das
gerade der ruhende Verkehr reduziert
wird das auch gerade auf öffentlich
Plätzen mehr Platz geschaffen würde sind
sehr weil wir auf der Seite das wollen
wir auch und da gibt es mit vernetzten
Verkehr mit automatisierten fahren was
irgendwann auch Realität sein wird und
mit Kommunikation unter den Fahrzeugen
so viel Potential und das ganze
Situation zu verbessern und das sollten
wir jetzt nutzen dazu kommt noch auch
natürlich der Ausbau von den
öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln damit es
einfach attraktiver gemacht wird damit
vielleicht wirklich ein paar Leute vom
Auto umsteigen auf die öffentlichen
Verkehrsmittel oder einfach sagen ok
kommen ich fahre von A nach B ich muss
gar nicht umsteigen sind nur zwei
Buchstaben ich erledige das dann doch
mit den öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln und
dass es so einfach müssen interessanter
wird und natürlich die Taktung auch
verkürzt wird das man nicht mehr so
lange Wartezeiten hat dass man auch
nicht irgendwie mit 40 50 60 anderen
Leuten sich in eine U-Bahn Waggon
quetscht sondern das ist einfach
angenehm ist damit zu fahren und hat
sogar eine wird gesagt dass wir gesagt
haben letzten Endes muss wirklich jede
Lebensrealität umfasst werden sowie der
Mobilität hat das ist euer
Kompromissvorschlag was sagt ihr grünes
würdet ihr euch auf die andere Seite
einen Schritt auf sie zu bewegen also
ich bin ja schon einen Schritt zurück
gegangen weil
ich finde es zwar gut voran der NVA
auszubauen aber gerade wenn es um die
Parkflächen geht finde ich es genau der
falsche Weg gerade in der Stadt aber ich
meine wenn ich mir überlege wir brauchen
hier Wohnraum oder Grünflächen alles
mögliche aber wirklich keine Parkhäuser
er wird das finde ich es total in die
falsche Richtung und da würde ich mich
auf jeden Fall gegen sperren lateral ist
das auch der Grund warum ihr stehen
geblieben seid nicht weit genug weil
diese Vincent mir alle vor 22 Jahren
schon haben können aber du verlierst
alles relativ neue Erkenntnisse deswegen
ich da bin wo ich jetzt bin und keinen
Schritt weiter gegangen weil ich dachte
ja auch Vincent Weisheit vielleicht
ändert sich das Vorschlag
der anderen
das dauert der Raum auch nur aufgeteilt
wird und das dann z.b. Parkraum
schrittweise reduziert wird und der Raum
beispielsweise in der Buslinie oder dem
Parkett zu gesprochen wird und ich darf
in Österreich beraten die Klimaschutz
Ministerin die Macht so dass sie immer
aus 1,5 Grad Ziel guckt sie will
Österreich zu einem bestimmten Punkt
klimaneutral haben und sie schaut drauf
was macht diese Maßnahmen die sie
umsetzen erreichen wir damit das Ziel er
oder fahren wir sogar noch zurück also
sowas wie Bonus-Malus-System das will
ich in Deutschland auch gern haben das
ist aber kein Kompromiss das ist nur da
eure Meinung dir weiterhin vertritt und
damit also Kompromisse wäre ja jetzt
irgendwie auf uns zu zu gehen um das
z.b. nicht alle Autos abgeschafft werden
müssten was wäre wenn kommt dann wieder
nicht noch nicht dass alle Autos
abgeschafft werden müssen sondern aus
dass ihr kriegt er weiterhin auch Geld
aber die anderen Systeme kriegen auch
Geld ich glaube das Problem bei dem
Kompromissvorschlag ist
Raul das war bei dir in der Osten
gebissen das was ich eigentlich schade
finde ist dieses Feindbild aufgebaut
wird der Autofahrer der Party Party der
Autor die Party der Automobilindustrie
das sind so diese alten Rollenbilder die
einfach wirklich also ich glaube wenn
man Zukunft denken will und Zukunft
machen will dann hilft es nicht zu
gucken was in der Vergangenheit
schiefgelaufen ist oder welche alten
Vorurteile man noch gegen gewisse
Gruppen hat sondern man muss sich halt
wirklich dem Hier und Jetzt stellen und
Dialog bereit sein und gucken wie kann
man einander irgendwie verstehen und
Lösung finden wir kommen nur dann weiter
wenn wir alle gemeinsam auf die bisher
geförderten einfach mal erklären was wir
legen Sie den letzten Jahrzehnten
eigentlich genossen haben von
Abwrackprämie wir sind zu alt war
kostenlos Liefern von Straßen dass wir
dann eben auch dafür genauso kämpfen
müssen dass es günstiger Alternativen
gibt das ist Ausbau der Deutschen Bahn
ist das ist die Weiterentwicklung von
älteren Frauen ist das ist weniger
Parkplätze und mehr Raum für Kinder und
Familien in Großstädten gibt wir haben
uns jetzt eure Seite auch mal angehört
die habt dann Zungenseite angehört und
wir haben halt auch ganz guten Vorschlag
eigentlich gemacht der ja irgendwie bei
euch auf Metall getroffen ist und er
vielleicht denkt er auch noch mal ein
bisschen drüber nach also beide Seiten
einfach mal
[Musik]
ihr habt ihr eure Punkte bereits genannt
ihr habt eure Punkte genannt und ihr
kommt nicht zusammen und das komplett ok
Fall dafür sind diesem Format auch Raum
trotzdem habt ihr genügend Kompromiss
Vorschläge und Argumente bereits
ausgetauscht und ich glaube so wie ihr
gerade steht das macht ja auch deutlich
wie schwierig diese Debatte ist und wie
viel häufiger wir vielleicht auch noch
in diesem Format und grundsätzlich in
der Gesellschaft darüber diskutieren
müssen deswegen danke ich euch dass ihr
euch zumindest so weit bewegt habt und
ja vielen Dank für die Diskussion ja ich
habe jetzt zum Beginn der Folge noch
komplett über ambitioniert gesagt dass
ich sehr optimistisch bin dass wir heute
den ein oder anderen Kompromiss finden
werden und seien wir mal ehrlich wären
eigentlich keinen wirklichen Kompromiss
gefunden jemand war am Ende und
Kompromiss fällt und das ist auch
komplett okay hat mich aber trotzdem
überrascht weil ich noch mal gemerkt
habe wie emotional diese eigentlich
ziemlich technische Debatte über
Mobilität am Ende dann doch ist und das
zeigt ja nur dass sie uns alle betrifft
wenn immer von dir sind Debatten sehen
wollt hier auf diesem Kanal dann folgt
dem sehr gerne könnte hier machen die
oben findet ihr ein weiteres Video von
dreizehn Fragen und die unten ein
weiteres Video zum Thema